quand on arrive à 30 feux simultanés on
atteint la capacité opérationnelle de la
surfure donc on a déjà dépassé cette
capacité là c'est pas une catastrophe le
faut pas à l'armer les gens ça veut
simplement dire que notre notre façon de
faire qui vise à éteindre tous les feux
dans notre zone de protection intensive
là on est plus capable d'atteindre cet
objectif là on doit prioriser les feux
on en parlait tout à l'heure avec les
mêmes restes à chapelle et à cette île
ils sont vraiment sur un pied d'alerte
qui ont déjà échappé évacué une partie
de la population des résidents mais les
risques d'incendie forestiers s'étend et
se multiplient dans plusieurs régions
Pays au Québec entre le bilan voulait
entendu de Monsieur Caron 42 incendies
puis vous voyez la carte là ici du
Québec officiellement mais la surface
attend à trouver d'autres
incendies dans les prochains jours mon
invité Philippe Gachon est professeur de
climatologie au Département des
géographie de lucasme spécialiste il
mérite de la prévisibilité des feux ce
qui serait très important monsieur
Gachon bonsoir est-ce qu'on peut parler
d'abord du fait que vous faites des
études sur la prévisibilité des feux
pour le compte de Ressources naturelles
Canada vous êtes à Lucas mais vous
terminez vos recherches hier plus on
vous a dit que si on avait pu ni Québec
nottawan a besoin désormais de recherche
la prévisibilité des feux est-ce que ça
qu'on peut dire un petit peu disons que
ce projet là on souhaite évidemment le
poursuivre notamment avec la souffure on
a discuté avec la sauce feu rencontrer
d'ailleurs au carrefour forêt il y a un
mois avec d'autres spécialistes dans le
domaine tout ce qui concerne la
prévention on a besoin de travailler
là-dessus rien du travail qui se fait
évidemment à Ressources naturelles
Canada en collaboration et environnement
Carla mais définitivement on a besoin de
mieux se préparer la prévivabilité c'est
aussi anticiper par exemple le démarrage
de la saison des feux on parle notamment
des feux à Chapet ou dans le Nord savoir
que il faut attendre que la neige fond
complètement sans précipitation au bout
de quatre jours la saison de redémarre
cette année ça a été particulier
c'est tout à fait c'est très tôt dans la
saison mais on a eu un espèce de moi de
mai un peu bizarre d'abord à chapelet
pour prendre l'exemple de Chapet on a eu
à peu près 26 mm de précipitation sur un
total normalement une normale de 84 donc
à peu près 30% de la totalité de ce
qu'on a normalement au mois au mois de
siècle c'est très sec on est passé de
l'hiver la semaine dernière ils ont
encore des nuits négatives puis quatre
jours plus tard il est 27 degrés donc
très sec et d'un seul coup il se met à
faire fait chaud le combustible en forêt
extrêmement inflammable surtout en début
de saison et là d'un seul coup les
premiers effectivement bon on parle
évidemment dans ce cas là de feu qui
sont pas d'origine naturelle on parle
éventuellement de feu d'origine humaine
qui ont été annoncés j'imagine allumé un
accidentellement mais le risque de feux
extrait extrêmement élevé donc faut
continuer à développer ces outils là de
prévisibilité pour être capable de mieux
se préparer avant l'arrivée de la saison
de feu surtout que
la sauce feu vient de publier d'autres
chiffres monsieur Caron était sur mon
collègue Patrice à 5h parlait de 42 feux
là c'est ce qu'on a entendu là on parle
de 70 feux puis lui il dit que la
capacité de la sauf feu c'est à 30 feux
on a atteint notre capacité
opérationnelle alors quel message
j'envoie ça alors c'est un message
important pour nos autorités d'ailleurs
au carrefour des forêts à ce feu
déclarait qu'ils étaient à limite de
leur capacité à la fois en termes
humains mais aussi en termes
d'infrastructures donc de pompiers de
pompiers d'avion ou d'infrastructures ou
d'un être capable d'intervenir donc
j'imagine bien que le gouvernement il
soit en attente justement une réponse du
gouvernement pour réinvestir notamment
sur sur la partie intervention mais il
en reste pas moins que quand bien même
on intervient il faut être capable de
prévenir en amont donc tout un travail
aussi à faire et c'est pour ça que la
collaboration avec les universités et
les gouvernements et fondamentales parce
que on forme la relève et on développe
aussi les compétences qui soient ensuite
par exemple embauché dans les ministères
donc il y a aussi du travail à faire en
collaboration pour non seulement
développer les outils mais s'assurer
qu'on forme la main d'oeuvre parce qu'on
sait tous qu'il y a une pénurie de la
malheur donc même la surfeuse si vous
voulez par exemple recruter aujourd'hui
les spécialistes en pompiers ou sécurité
civile il faut les former à la fois dans
les universités ou ailleurs et
j'investis de ce feu vont aider d'autres
communautés de même dans d'autres pays
on apprend qu'au Canada qu'on va faire
venir des gens notamment des États-Unis
et de l'Afrique du Sud donc on est tout
à fait le Canada si on a des feux comme
on voit évidemment cette année c'est
particulier on a eu une école un nouvel
école mais si on a des feux Causses tous
causes on est à la limite de notre
capacité à l'intervention d'abord un on
n'a pas les ressources humaines de on
n'a pas les équipements nécessaires
non si on a vraiment des feux de grande
envergure on est obligé de faire appel
dans l'ouest on a fait appel de toute
façon à l'Australie et à
Nouvelle-Zélande la seule fois je pense
que tu allais aidé aussi un bout de
temps qu'ils ont ramené évidemment leur
matériel de l'équipement parce que nous
on démarrait notre saison de feu donc le
Canada à la limite de sa capacité à
l'heure actuelle surtout si les feux de
forêt continuent à prendre l'ampleur qui
voit qu'on voit en ce moment au Québec
il a la saison ne fait que commencer il
me semble moi je me souviens pas de
d'une situation comme celle que l'on vit
actuellement à savoir d'est en ouest au
pays tout en même temps fin mai début
juin un Alberta ça a commencé à 15 jours
tout à fait et je regardais avant de
venir en ondes appeler la sécheresse
l'ampleur de la sécheresse à travers le
pays mais c'est vraiment majeur non
seulement on a les prairies qui sont
dans un état particulièrement sec avec
la chaleur qu'on a vu évidemment très
très tôt cet été
au printemps mais là c'est en train
d'infecter maintenant l'est on avait eu
comme je disais tout à l'heure on a un
déficit de précipitation au mois de mai
mais on annonce pas de précipitation
majeure au cours des prochains jours
voire même éventuellement pour le mois
de juin fait que là on va se retrouver
dans une situation où l'ensemble du pays
va se retrouver avec des risques de feu
extrêmement importants et si jamais en
plus on a des canicules comme c'était ça
s'est produit évidemment c'est la
dernière année ça peut prendre des
ampleurs effectivement inusité on parle
depuis ici la mais on parle d'orage
ailleurs l'orage est source évidemment
de déclenchement l'incendie c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on a besoin de faire du
travail parce que les impacts de foudre
faut comprendre exactement d'abord où il
se produit comment ça fonctionne
exactement puis éventuellement quel type
d'orage ou quel type d'impact peut
générer éventuellement le déclenchement
l'incendie puis ça c'est pas partout ça
se produit on sait par exemple au Canada
les endroits où on ne les impacts de
rage les plus importants de foudre c'est
les prairies le sud du Québec est donc à
Rio mais tout ça est en train de changer
avec le changement climatique donc pour
ça que ça prend la surveillance et aussi
des outils pour être capable de mieux
anticiper tous ces changements ici c'est
au début on a le Bertin parlait de cause
humaine ici aussi c'est la chapelle
cette île c'est ce que j'ai entendu
c'est surtout des reliés à l'activité
humaine les mégots des visites en forêt
des ouais parce que là en début de la
saison de camping comment on fait beau
que les gens veulent à l'extérieur c'est
tout à fait compréhensible mais il peut
y avoir éventuellement des orages là on
attend de toute façon les orages au
cours de fin de semaine on va avoir une
diminution des températures donc ça va
aider
mais il faudrait pas éventuellement que
on n'est pas assez de précipitation puis
que le temps sac perdure parce que là
effectivement ça va augmenter les
risques
qui sont dangereux dans une certaine
séquence et c'est caniculaire ou des 25
ou des 25 degrés à partir du moment où
le combustible en forêt et sec c'est
quoi le combustible tout par exemple
quand les feuilles sont restées sous la
neige elle s'assèche évidemment pendant
l'hiver et quand il y a pas de
précipitation c'est un combustible c'est
un qui est extrêmement sec les feuilles
non seulement mais les herbes c'est
extrêmement sèche surtout quand il y a
pas de précipitation de façon importante
et on sait que les incendies au début de
la saison
sont particulièrement on va dire
problématique parce que le combustible
l'inflammabilité des forêts présentes
très bien Philippe Gachon message qu'on
doit retenir au fond à l'endroit des
autorités puis pour les citoyens
antérieurs alors il faut travailler à
augmenter notre capacité d'intervention
ça c'est clair ce feu la déjà dit mais
aussi quand même de ressources
à mieux s'équiper et travailler en amont
en prévention en préparation
sensibilisation aussi on parle
évidemment des risques de feu d'origine
humaine donc travaille aussi bien en
avant en disant faites attention quand
vous sortez en forêt en ce moment les
risques sont très élevés la sauce feu la
déclaré mais il y a du travail de
sensibilisation à faire et surtout je
termine en rétablissement parce que les
populations qui perdent leur maison tous
leurs biens c'est les drames humains
donc il y a aussi du travail à faire
aussi à rétablir les personnes pour
juste les bien merci les personnes
[Musique]
en terminant je suis assez vieille pour
avoir connu le trajet incendie criminel
de Chapet une veille du jour de l'an qui
avait fait 35 mort leur chapelet les
feux ça veut dire quelque chose
merci beaucoup j'espère l'occasion de se
reparler mais dans des circonstances
positives pour partager votre expertise
merci merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]